In 1854, a man stood on [music] a
platform suspended above the ground and
he told the person behind him to cut
[music] the rope that was holding him
up. And what happened next not only
changed an entire industry forever, but
[music] revealed the most powerful
persuasion tactic in copywriting today.
And [music] if you can master this one
thing, you can sell anything to anyone.
Here's what happened next. Meet Elijah
Otis. It's 1854. [music] He's 41 years
old and he's living in Yonkers, New
York. He's bounced from job to job his
entire [music] life. Carpenter, sawmill
operator, wagon maker, and then his
first wife died, leaving him with two
young children. He also had chronic
health problems. This guy could not
catch a break. [music] But while he was
working at a bedstead factory, Otis
needed to hoist heavy machinery to the
upper floors. So he invented a very
simple safety break for [music] the
wagon spring so that if the rope broke,
metal teeth would catch the shaft on the
way down and stop the fall. And then it
hit him. I could use this for elevators.
And at the time in 1854, if you rode an
elevator and the cable snapped, you
plummeted to your [music] death, which
made a lot of people take the stairs. So
he reworks his invention for elevators
and he starts reaching out to elevator
manufacturers. He tells him, "If the
cable [music] snaps, this invention will
save your life." And nobody believed him
except for a guy named PT Barnum. He
offered Elijah Otis $100 to demonstrate
his invention at the New York World's
Fair in Crystal Palace. Otis took the
hundred bucks. So now he's at the World
Fair. He's standing on the platform,
hoisted above everyone else. He looks at
his assistant who's standing right next
to [music] him holding an axe right next
to the rope and he says, "Cut it." She
swings. The crowd freaks out and the
rope snaps. The platform [music] starts
dropping until it stops dead cold. Otis'
safety break had caught him and he
stands there with his arms out wide and
he says, "All safe, gentlemen." That
single demonstration launched the Otis
elevator company. Today they move 2
billion people per day in their
elevators. That's over 30% of the entire
human population around the world. All
[music] because he used the single
greatest persuasion tactic we have at
our disposal. Demonstration as proof or
DAP for short. So let me tell you what
demonstration as proof is. Demonstration
is when you show don't tell that your
product or idea [music] works. It's the
difference between saying this car is
fast and showing someone a video of your
car going 0 to 60 in 3 seconds. [music]
Proof has been around for centuries when
it comes to sales and persuasion. But
there is a hierarchy of proof from
weakest to strongest. Starting with
promise as the weakest. Promise is you
saying our [music] product is the best.
But stronger than promise right above it
is testimonials. This is other people
saying their product is the best. But
above testimonials is a territory very
few people go into and that is
demonstration. Demonstration says,
[music] "Watch it work right now."
Demonstration is at the top of the proof
hierarchy because it removes the most
objections in the quickest amount of
time. Your audience is no longer
trusting you or someone else. They are
trusting their own eyes. In fact, I want
to break down the science of why
demonstration [music] as proof is so
strong when it comes to sales,
persuasion, and copywriting. Science
fact number one, seeing is believing.
Our brains process [music] visual
information 60,000 times faster than
text. When we see something work, we
cannot unsee it. It becomes undeniable.
Number two is it eliminates the
imagination gap. When you just tell
someone about the benefits of your
product, [music] they have to imagine it
themselves. Most people can't or won't
do that, but demonstration does it for
them. Number three is it triggers mirror
neurons. When we watch someone do
something, your brain simulates the
experience as if you were doing it.
Number four is it removes all risk
perception. When something works right
in front of us, our brains think, "This
is no longer a gamble. I just saw it
happen." But even with these key
elements, not every demonstration is
equally strong. There are six
characteristics that can make or break
your demonstration as proof. Here are
those six key elements that you can
inject directly into your copy or sales
pitch [music] to make it significantly
more persuasive. Number one, high
stakes. The demonstration has to matter.
Otis could have put 50 lbs of bricks on
the platform and said, "Cut the rope."
But it wouldn't have mattered. So, he
put himself on the line and life or
death became the stakes. That's
infinitely more memorable and
convincing. Another example could be
like Billy Mays throwing a brick at a
car window and saying, [music] "Hey,
look, it didn't break." versus just
tapping the window with his fingers and
saying, "Ah, it's a really durable
window." Do you see the difference?
Number two, unedited. People have to
believe that they are watching something
genuine that it's not manufactured. A
great example would be like writing copy
live for a client. It's being on the
phone and say, "Hey, I'll write this
right now. We'll send the email and we
will watch the sales come in together."
There's no hiding behind chatbt. It's
real. It's raw. It's unedited and the
stakes are high. Number three is a
relatable context. Your demonstration
should happen in a context that is
relatable to the people you are trying
to persuade. It's exactly why Otis did
it at the World's Fair in Crystal Palace
instead of saying, "Hey, everybody come
to my warehouse where it's already set
up." So, you need to think, what habits,
systems, or environments do my ideal
audience already [music] function in
that I can inject my idea or product and
change the result they're getting?
Number four is a visible transformation.
There has to be a before and after, and
the change needs to be obvious. It could
be a stain disappearing out of a couch
or a task instantly becoming automated
or someone's Stripe account getting
sales because of the email that you
sent. You have to make the result of the
demonstration dead obvious. Number five
is repeatability signal. This is the
ability to demonstrate that you can do
it again and again and again. You have
to prove it's not a one-time flute. I.e.
if you send another email, will you
still make sales? And last one, number
six, is you have to address the core
objection. Your demonstration should
target the biggest reason people don't
buy. Otis knew that people feared
elevators because if it snaps, [music]
they die. So, he demonstrated the safety
that would save them from their death in
the most extreme way possible. And that
is demonstration as proof. And to wrap
us up, here's what I want you to do
next. I want you to write down what's
the one thing about your product,
service, or idea that people don't
believe? And then ask yourself, how can
I show them instead [music] of tell
them? Can you film it? Can you do it
live? Can you write a story? Can you
create a before and after? And then you
inject that into your copy, your VSSL,
your sales letter, your meta ads. And I
guarantee that your conversion rate will
go up and your sales will go up. And if
this changed how you think about
persuasion and copywriting and sales, I
would love for you to like the video and
subscribe to the channel. It tells me
that you want me to make more content
just like this. And in the meantime, I
have a free resource for you before you
go down in the description below and
pinned as a comment is copywriting
catalyst, which is 63 cash cow
copywriting secrets just like this one
to help you write more persuasive sales
[music] copy for your business product
or ideas. It's in the link in the
description below. Feel free to grab it.
I hope this video was helpful. I
appreciate you watching. Share it if you
enjoyed it and I will catch you on the
next one. Man, that was a good one. Oh
my goodness. I'm sitting here
demonstrating all my wisdom. Bam. Right.
Live in front of you. That's
demonstration. What are you What are you
still doing here? Watch more videos. You
can watch more. You can click. There's
like a bunch of them. I made so many. I
make one of these every single week.
It's free. This is unbelievable. I can't
believe this is free.
Oh my goodness.